en 1982 je suis parti de bourges à
compostelle pour compostelle avec mes
enfants adolescents et à cheval qu'elle
100 km en autonomie totale et sans
assistance technique en fait
encouragements j'ai surtout eu de
nombreuses critiques me traitant de
maires irresponsables l'époque je
partais sur la fois des connaissances
qui prévalent encore aujourd'hui à
compostelle afflux affluaient au
moyen-âge des millions de pèlerins venus
se recueillir sur la tombe de saint
jacques le majeur apôtres du christ
ils étaient venus par des routes
spécialement dessiné pour eux
pratiquement et ils étaient accueillis
dans des lieux qui leur était réservée
cette équipe et devait être sans
lendemain mais elle a en fait très
orienté toute ma vie je suis rentré avec
tant de questions de ce pèlerinage que
je suis parti chercher trouve trouve
chercher des réponses à l'université
pour y apprendre le métier d'historien
parce que je n'avais pas envie de rester
amateur
autrement dit j'ai repris les chemins de
saint jacques
mais sur les chemins de la connaissance
j'espérais y trouver ces millions de
pèlerins dont on parle étant entre
autres et dans mon enthousiasme de
néophytes j'ai bien cru d'abord les
avoir trouvés mais très vite mais m mon
priés d'utiliser les méthodes de
l'historien d'une pas me laisser
emporter et de relire les textes dans
leur version originale
à intégral et surtout dépouillé de tout
commentaire et le térieur alors ses
textes c'était quoi
c'était des chroniques des registres
d'hôpitaux décompte des actes notariés
des récits de pèlerins etc
je les ai relu évidemment avec un autre
regard et là mes convictions se sont
vite envolés
parce que des pèlerins il y en avait
beaucoup mais très très peu arriver à
compostelle après cinq ans
d'apprentissage à l'université et 8 ans
pour préparer ma thèse sur saint-jacques
je travaillais à mi temps paris 1
sorbonne va décerner le titre de docteur
en histoire je devenais c'était magique
la seule médiéviste française
spécialiste de saint jacques et
compostelle la double casquette de
pèleriner d'historienne m'avait permis
d'adopter une démarche originale et de
d'aborder la question sous un angle
nouveau
j'avais fait un nouveau pas et
j'arrivais à commencer à comprendre
comment s'était construite cette idée du
pèlerinage à compostelle au fil des
siècles
alors pour vous aider à comprendre
derrière moi je vous invite garder dans
la tête quatre moments clés que je vais
vous résumer rapidement premier de ces
moments c'est un texte qui émane de la
bible donc le plus ancien des textes et
qui dit que saint jacques était un ami
proche du christ lequel l'avait surnommé
le fils du tonnerre à cause du temps de
son tempérament belliqueux et il a été
décapité à jérusalem
en l'an quarante quatre parce qu'il
avait prêché la doctrine du christ
et c'est autour de ce maigre bagage
historique que s'est construite toute
l'aura du pèlerinage à compostelle
parce que à partir de ces images selon
l'écho les circonstances et selon les
besoins
ça jacques a été tantôt valeureux
guerriers tantôt à douze apôtres
deuxième moment clé dans cette histoire
après huit siècles de silence au 9e
siècle on retrouve le tombeau de saint
jacques à compostelle il est tué à
jérusalem il est enterré à compostelle
comment et pourquoi
comment on n'en sait strictement rien
seuls les légendes peuvent expliquer
pourquoi la l'histoire répond à ce
moment là l'espagne chrétienne est
envahie par les infidèles lessard asa
elle se cherche à saint patron et elle
pense tout naturellement à ce fils du
tonnerre mais à saint patron n'est
crédible que s'il ya son tombeau est ce
donc une des circonstances qui explique
pourquoi on l'a retrouvé ce tombeau
miraculeusement alors de fête saint
jacques est apparue dans le ciel des
batailles sur un cheval blanc
brandissant une épée et apportant la
victoire il y a gagné le titre de
saint-jacques matamore le tueur de mort
et les côtes ses exploits s'est répandu
dans toute l'europe
si bien qu'en même temps la renommée de
compostelle a suivi troisième point
eh bien on arrive au 19e siècle au 19e
siècle où il ya grand besoin de re
christianisé l'europe
après diverses révolutions et aux
réinterprète la piété médiévale en
particulier on remet à l'honneur
beaucoup de pèlerinage anciens on en
crée des nouveaux c'est ainsi que
lourdes
l'aîné je pense à lourdes avec les
chemins de fer
quant à compostelle l'archevêque pour
attirer des pèlerins lance une grande
campagne alors en deux temps tout
d'abord pour faire taire les doutes sur
l'authenticité des reliques de saint
jacques
il fait procéder est fait des fouilles
on retrouve les reliques et il les fait
authentifier par le pacte seconde
éléments il ressort de ces archives un
magnifique manuscrit du 12ème siècle
qu'il confie à des érudits avec mission
d'interpréter les textes bien sûr dans
l'air du temps à leur premier texte
il s'agit d'une longue liste qui bien
opportunément énumère les millions de
pèlerins qui viennent à compostelle
depuis la découverte du tombeau et il ya
des noms les mèdes les parts les et
l'ami tu es ce que les érudits n'ont pas
dit c'est que ce texte était copié mot
pour mot dans la bible chapitre 2 des
actes des apôtres et écrit bien sûr dans
une toute autre optique
c'était courant au moyen-âge ce type de
copies dans ce même manuscrit
les érudits en trouver à l'autre texte
qu'ils ont nommée guide du pèlerin il du
pèlerin tout le monde le connaît
aujourd'hui sauf que ce n'était pas un
guide et le texte n'avait pas été écrit
pour les pèlerins mais ils ont quand
même présenté ce document comme premier
guide touristique un premier guide
michelin au guide du routard dans ce
même texte ils ont trouvé les quatre
chemins
quatre chemins qui n'était pas davantage
un itinéraire mais qui sont devenus les
chemins itinéraire historique
d'aujourd'hui
quatrièmes et derniers moments clés on
arrive à l'époque de franco
alors franco je vous sans frémir franco
c'est la guerre civile franco était un
galicien élevé dans la dévotion à saint
jacques et pendant la guerre civile
pour combattre les répudier des rouges
il a combattu sous la bannière de
saint-jacques matamore auquel il a
redonné son costume de guerrier et le
tueur de mort est devenue le tueur de
rouge après la seconde guerre mondiale
franco a redonné à saint jacques son
costume de doux pèlerins pourquoi parce
qu'il avait besoin de lui pour réouvrir
l'espagne à l'europe
et c'est ainsi que saint jacques à
attirer de nouveaux pèlerins et qu'il a
commencé à attirer le 24 25 juillet
pardon 1948 franco exprimé le voeu je
cite d'ouvrir le chemin de saint-jacques
jusqu'au delà du rideau de fer
il a été exaucé longtemps après en 1987
quand le conseil de l'europe a nommé le
camino francès première itinéraire
culturel européen puis en 93
lorsque l'unesco a inscrit ce même
camino au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité
alors la saint jacques était vraiment au
service de l'europe et l'est resté à
partir de la dalle pèlerinage a changé
complètement d'optique les pèlerins
newedge ont admis au admise cette vision
du moyen-âge revisité et ils ont ajouté
un élément supplémentaire qui a tout
changé
ils ont fabriqué la marche à pied c'est
eux qui ont inventé la marche à pied
parce que l leur semblait indispensable
pour revivre cet âge d'or de la lenteur
alors progressivement le pèlerinage a
changé d'esprit
il est passé de la piété médiévales
européennes à la recherche de soi même
à la quête spirituelle aux rencontres
voire même à l' aventure sans risque
je l' ai entendu vivre l'aventuré sans
risque et cette aventure effectivement
pouvait se vivre sur ce chemin mais ce
chemin progressivement aussi est devenu
plus important que le sanctuaire il a
pris le pas sur les hauteur et jeudi
d'une façon peut être un peu désagréable
que ça camino est en train de supplanter
saint jacques
alors ça c'est au grand dam des
chanoines de compostelle et puis au mien
finalement parce que moi j'avais envie
ancien pèlerine et ancienne enseignante
de faire partager mes connaissances
c'était une utopie
est ce que vous auriez aujourd'hui
l'idée de remonter la loire en crue à la
rame
sûrement pas moi c'était pareil et
j'étais devenu au contraire une briseuse
de rêves et mon propre rêve à moi qu'est
ce qu'il était devenu
et bien pour voir je suis reparti à
compostelle à pied cette fois en 2001
pour 100 km et là j'ai vécu un second
pèlerinage avec un imaginaire qui
tournait autour des récifs pèlerins que
j'avais lu et je revivais leur leur
aventure je marchais aussi pour tous
ceux qui avaient révélé à compostelle et
qui n'avait pas pu y aller et je
comprenais mieux aussi le patrimoine
hérité des cultes à saint jacques en
particulier c'est monumentale statue de
saint-jacques piétinant les infidèles
sous les pieds de son cheval et j'avais
aussi fait mon propre chemin
j'avais trouvé ça plus amusant que de
suivre les balises et les flèches jaunes
et ses balises qui font que finalement
le chemin de saint jacques est devenu
une espèce de grand de grandes scènes de
théâtre alors je m'explique
sur cette scène sont les acteurs
principaux les pèlerins en costume
décathlon est au bord du chemin
eh bien on trouve des hospitaliers qui
sont souvent d'anciens pèlerins qu'ils
veulent continuer à vivre leur
pèlerinage on trouve les paysans du gers
dont certains ne font plus de canard ni
de maïs mais font du pèlerin on trouve
les offices du tourisme qui pour montrer
prouver leur position d' étape majeure
sur le chemin de compostelle le
craignent pas d'affirmer y passait par
là sans autre forme et autour de tout ça
il ya tout un déchaînement médiatique
qui fige l'histoire aux interprétations
du 19e refusant d'aller voir plus loin
à tel point que grande majorité de
terrain vous en faites peut-être partie
finissent par y perdre tout sens
critique et pourtant les pèlerins qu'ils
le veuillent ou non les pèlerins font
partie de cette histoire leur marche est
au coeur de l'histoire elle y prend ses
racines ce n'est pas pour par hasard que
depuis 15 ils sont sur un chemin dont on
parle depuis 200 ans
et ils y sont et puis qu'il en soit
conscient ou non il participe à la
création d'une nouvelle histoire
alors comment mais il fabrique de
nouveaux mythes il crée des rituels il
transforme des coutumes anciennes et
finalement l'histoire n'est pas figé il
contribue à la continuer alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire de l'évolution future de
ce pèlerinage
je ne suis pas prophète mais j'ai quand
même du mal à penser qu'il va passer
comme passe toutes les modes
le singulier par exemple peut très bien
surgir à nouveau devant la montée de
l'islamisme radical
j'en ai pour preuve qu'on l'a vu
réapparaître en 2003 ainsi que le relate
le quotidien madrilène el mundo des 24
et 25 juillet de cette année là je cite
les troupes que l'espagne a envoyé en
irak des filons en terre sainte avec la
croix de saint jacques matamore bien
visible sur leurs bannières et leurs
drapeaux
les caricatures je le pense
disparaîtront comme une mode justement
je l'espère parce que déjà davantage de
pèlerins cherche à marcher avec leur
tête en même temps qu'avec leur coeur
est avec leurs jambes et ils veulent
savoir davantage il questionne ils
demandent ils veulent démêler l'histoire
de la légende qui n'enlève rien à la
magie de leur chemin et je pense que
c'est eux qui diffuseront les nouvelles
connaissances
alors quand à moi je continue à
pellerinais dans les archives pour
augmenter notre legs aux historiens du
futur
et vous alors vous que je ne peux que
vous inviter à rentrer dans cette
nouvelle histoire en prenant le chemin
de saint jacques en empruntant les
chemins de terre mais aussi les chemins
de la connaissance et je vous dis comme
disent les espagnols aux pèlerins qui
passe et bien boyne kami no mercy